c'est pas un déguisement c'est la vraie
combien coûte c'est vrai ça coûte cette
merde celle-ci 2200 diamants elle serait
estimée à 3 milliards
sur la tête oui mais ce n'est qu'une
estimation Cyril parce que aucune
compagnie d'assurance n'accepte
évidemment d'assurer la chose parce que
c'est tout simplement inestimable
c'est là tu lui prends la couronne frère
2200 diamants dont des diamants
complètement mais bon c'est dur ça doit
pas être facile à revendre
pour une galette des rois et ramené ça
c'est pas facile à revendre et c'est
très difficile à porter bah peut-être
que l'occasion lors de la cérémonie on
va lui faire plaisir
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est pas mal il y a un délire c'est le
roi et la reine c'est le roi et la reine
absolument
bah oui j'étais émis quand même depuis
le temps que je parle du couronnement
ici maintenant que ça a été fait tu vas
te faire
alors on va voir
[Applaudissements]
la scène que l'on vient de voir là il
était précisément 13h02 en français à
13h pile pardon oui il y a un petit
décalage
très bien le français pour le colis de
maison en Normandie a saisi la couronne
celle-ci c'est celle de Saint-Édouard
c'est pas la même que celle de tout à
l'heure vous savez il y a deux couronnes
qui ont été utilisés il a saisi comment
ça fait-il que l'endroit de l'envers il
y avait un petit truc qui avait été mise
au point il y avait une petite croix une
petite croix de Ré c'est comme ça qu'il
a su que c'était l'endroit et il a posé
en effet la couronne à l'envers et on
voit un effet qu'il est hésitant et que
il y a une vice presque la couronne il
la pose il a repose c'est lourd cette
connerie là 2230 grammes
2 on sait qu'il t'as 2 kg 2 sur la tête
voilà mais absolument
voilà deux sacs un peu plus oui et alors
vous voyez qu'il a les deux sceptre dans
dans les mâles le sceptre de la justice
et le sceptre à la colombe et vous voyez
le bandeau ce que l'on appelle le
bandeau de la couronne ce qui paraît
comme une barre de coton bien sûr et
bien c'est cela en réalité
un peu il est écologique si si si si
c'est tout ça du vrai
on dirait
des trucs avec des trucs
on dirait qu'il les a eu dans les trucs
là quand tu prends des balles là la
Foire du tout je vous assure que c'est
vrai 444 précieuses en effet Kelly il y
a une reproduction parfaite qui a été
utilisée pour s'entraîner pour moi c'est
entraîné pendant de nombreuses semaines
je ne pense pas non mon père il adore
les couronnes
et donc la fameuse bande d'hermine et
ben en réalité qui n'est pas de
l'Hermine c'est du synthétique et ben
c'est ce qui permet vraiment de la
couronne tienne sur sa tête sinon ça ne
tiendrait absolument pas du tout en
effet voilà à ce moment-là Cyril petit
ombre peut-être la BBC espérait faire
plus ou moins à 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs au moment où la couronne
serait posée bah il semble que il n'y
arrive pas du tout on serait plutôt de
l'ordre des deux milliards plutôt que
des personnes qui ont vu le gars se
mettent se mettre une couronne
alors il est parti en puissance après en
carrosse il est parti dans les parties
en hoverboard et puis ils ont carrément
dans un carrosse presque de vieux de 300
ans
de Georges 3 4 tonnes d'or il est plaqué
à la feuille d'or il faut 8 chevaux
obligatoirement blanc et au pack pour
pouvoir le tracter et il ne peut être
utilisé que leur des couronnements ou
des Jubilés ce qui veut donc dire Siri
Jupiler de roi d'Angleterre et il faut
savoir que le premier jubilé de roi
c'est à l'occasion de 25 ans de règne il
y a très peu de chances que Charles III
fasse 25 ans qu'est-ce qu'il a 74 ans
déjà 99 la prochaine fois qu'on verra ce
carrosse ce sera l'heure du courant
je le connais lui c'est lui c'est un
rock lui il nous enterrera tout de suite
regardez quand ils se sont barrés là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cette voiture aucun système de
frein système de suspension
il avait des épines il avait des épines
pour le faire freiner il faut 90 m donc
90 m auparavant et sachez que il n'avait
absolument rien mangé ni rien bu non il
va avoir une maladie
tu vas avoir une haleine de Ramadan
pourquoi Cyril parce que ça bouge elle
va avoir une haleine de Kippour je
connais les gars ils viennent de parler
frère ils ont une haleine mon frère on
dirait qu'ils ont du cuir dans la bouche
mais ça ça bouge tellement que Élisa
fait au matin de ton couronnement
Charles tu ne mangeras rien pourquoi
parce que on a table son couronnement
ils avaient deux elle a failli vomir
tellement ça bouge je vous assure ça n'a
rien mangé non il a dû prendre un petit
maquereau il se dit que Nice frère
arrête il se dit que il déjeune jamais
le moins cher une petite déjà mais il ne
déjeune petit déjeuner il mange le soir
et ça fait on lui présente trois œufs à
la coque pour être sûr que au moins l'un
de ses œufs est à la cuisson qu'il le
souhaite et les deux autres il n'y
touchent pas un sport
[Rires]
il y a Patrick hein
c'est Andrew et alors donc bon ah il a
salué la foule et tu veux que je te dise
la vérité oui j'ai vu Charles je sentais
pas en immense darka parce que la vérité
tu deviens roi moi je suis revenu après
je fais
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire avec moi tu
sais je fais des je fais des doigts et
toi la foule
je fais des doigts à la
foule ouais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive ouais
tranquille on s'en bat les couilles
est-ce que vous vous imaginez la
pression qu'il avait sur ses épaules
quand cette cérémonie elle a duré
pendant 2 ans
oui mais c'est symboliquement très fort
durant les deux heures de cérémonie je
vous assure que la moindre étape la
moindre minute puisqu'on sait d'ailleurs
qu'il y a eu 5 minutes qui qui ont posé
problème quand il a été bloqué
la moindre minute elle est parfaitement
qu'est-ce qu'elle dise ce qui explique
en effet vous avez raison on ne lâche
jamais vu aussi nerveux aussi parle
aussi stressé bien sûr j'ai senti
rassera de ouf pour savoir en fait tu le
connais bien non mais je te jure je l'ai
pas senti bien j'ai failli l'appeler moi
non plus 5 minutes
[Rires]
regardez regardez
j'ai les acclamations bien sûr vois ça
voilà le roi et la reine Charlotte III
Camille
on vit cette ambiance on écoute
l'ambiance justement à Londres devant le
palais du Kingham
[Applaudissements]
la toute première fois qu'il est apparu
sur ce balance
la première fois là qu'il apparaît en
tant que roi
il a l'air vraiment pas bien hein
[Applaudissements]
mais au moment vraiment de la cérémonie
il est blanc blanc
qui n'a pas pu être filmé pendant les
caméras de la BBC qui a duré 2 minutes
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'onction et à ce
moment-là tu te souviens on considère
que c'est Dieu qui descend sur Terre et
déjà le missionné et l'arche avec des
counter Bury lui dit désormais tu seras
lieutenant de Dieu sur terre pour les 85
millions en cliquant il est chef
spirituel ah ça n'arrive quand même pas
à tout le monde alors on s'en fout
peut-être c'est peut-être rassera machin
à vous elle était plus détendue à la
limite
elle ne devient pas le lieutenant que
Dieu sur terre elle devient quoi elle
fait pas quoi à côté c'est
un peu la mini oui la mini du jour
[Rires]
[Musique]
il était là il est embout avec toute la
famille royale il est bienvenu il est
venu sans sa femme oui Mégane meuble
regardez harry était là comment il faut
que tu nous dises des infos là-dessus tu
en as ou bien absolument
[Rires]
[Musique]
lui il a une tête à avoir pris un billet
lui
il a pris un billet pour venir chez moi
c'est celui qui rigole le plus il est
venu il est sans sa femme il a dû aller
là-bas
il a pris un billet sa femme elle était
chez plouf frère il va dire je vais au
courant mon dieu c'est la meilleure
frère
il est comme un ouf il a pris un billet
en plus frère à vous ça peut être la
vérité
cette information
qu'il a été habillé par la maison Dior
gratuitement qui avait immédiatement à
tweeté que la maison d'hier elle avait
réalisé un morning coach une veste de
jour comme vous voyez là ce qu'on
appelle une jaquette ça d'accord il faut
que je suit d'autres marques
voilà Damien était habillé Bruce
qui est un grand couturier
ça parce que c'était le couturier Diana
le couturier préféré donc elle a choisi
c'est vrai alors couturier bon un peu un
peu étrange peut-être
on peut peut-être dire quête et Kate
évidemment par la maison Alexander
McQueen
elle est appelée par la maison Alexander
il aurait pas pu acheter un manteau
celui-là
parce qu'il était connu donc il recycle
c'est une barre de fer celui-là je donne
mon tout
pour mon père jeune homme
sur ma vie Cyril ce qu'on peut peut-être
dire c'est qu'elle est quand même divine
regardez c'est d'Irlande de fleurs
de l'environnement bah oui je sais donc
tu crois vraiment que c'est un cours de
la fleur en hommage à Charles III
absolument et si jamais la nature
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et alors le protocole première fois que
vous vous adressez au roi c'est votre
Majesté je vous match hier ça va
j'arrive en Angleterre je veux dire how
are you ma gueule
tu peux tenter
c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'air ça
a pas bon voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup d'humour non c'est vrai ah je
rigole rideau genre tu dis il y a une
soirée tu fais une barquin
mais on le voit tout le temps audio avec
ses équipes à chaque fois il est tout le
temps
un peu
d'autorités
[Rires]
à Moscou
tranquillement à London
je peux dire moi j'adore moi j'adore
j'adore je peux en être fier alors il y
a eu un moment où forcément c'est la
seule image qu'on a pas prise c'est
normal c'est notre marque de fabrique
[Rires]
c'est la seule image qu'il fallait
prendre quand on est partout c'est la
seule qu'on a pas prise je l'ai derrière
sans le son voilà donc c'est toujours
comme ça c'est ça qui est important
voilà voilà donc là on entendait alors
ils sont en train de me dire on
entendait pas même à la tête donc ils
ont raison mais on voit on se voit ce
vénère là il a l'air vénère frère
il a pas mangé il a une année il a une
année de vieux cuire
le vieux par-dessus râpé frère il est
vénère de ouf il se dit qu'une envie là
c'est que tous ces cons on rentre les
deux avec moi j'aille dormir j'aille
manger tranquille là il a lui je te jure
là il pense qu'à un truc là il se dit
frère j'ai envie de manger un tajine RAM
regarde sur ma vie vas-y vas-y ils sont
tous venus ils vont me mettre la
couronne j'ai envie de Gémeaux moi donc
qu'est-ce qu'il a eu là je vous ai dit
qu'il y a de nombreuses répétitions ont
eu lieu on a chronométré en réalité que
pour se présenter devant la porte ouest
il devait être précisément 11h ce Nantes
hors anglaise et il fallait sept minutes
que pour pouvoir remonter avec le
manteau de cours la robe et tout ça donc
il a été chronométré 11h à anglaise donc
le Carros deux années précisément
arriver à 10h53 puisqu'il fallait 7
minutes pour que vous me suivez pour
arriver à 11 après et bien donc le
trajet a été chronométré durant les
répétitions le trajet devait mettre 32
minutes pour quitter le palais à
l'abbaye de Westminster et en réalité
les 6 chevaux les 6 Windsor Grey qui a
été mené par Tyron c'était le nom du
cheval de tête
un peu trop rapide ils ont effectué ce
trajet en 27 ans ce qui veut donc dire
que il arrive avec 5 minutes d'avance et
il est persuadé qu'on va le faire ce
réseau alors donc attends parce que donc
là il y a le roi il arrive avec 5000 ans
tu vas attendre comme tout le monde je
peux te dire tu vas attendre comme tout
le monde et tu vas arrêter de faire
chier ton de l'assistance mais c'est
plus ou moins ce qui est arrivé pourquoi
non pourquoi parce que elle est
inhérente au duc de nerfolk c'est duc de
Norfolk est le seul à origan magnifique
c'est le plus vieux duc du royaume
durant du royaume oui mais il est pas
vieux Shop c'est pas son âge tellement
on s'en fout un peu de son âge il vient
de la famille la plus prestigieuse et la
plus ancienne famille parfois la famille
de Norfolk il s'appelle Edward c'est son
petit nom Edouard de norfiste
il a fait en charge l'organisation du
couronnement comme il a eu en charge
d'ailleurs l'organisation des
funérailles c'est lui le grand
orchestrateur de la cour bref et en
effet Charles c'est une fois un peu sur
Camille ya et en gros il lui dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait allez
il y a des spécialistes qui ont eu lieu
ici il a dit nous ne serons jamais à
l'heure elle a on sait pas ce qu'elle a
répondu et il a dit oui je sais c'est
négatif mais on ne sait pas ce qu'elle
lui a répondu donc arrêtez ce n'est pas
négatif du tout puisque ils ne font que
respecter le protocole à 53 Cyril vous
pouvez vérifier la porte s'est ouverte
le marche-pied a été déplié et ils sont
descendus oui mais quand même un truc
c'est que oui
illiam sont arrivés en retard et ils
sont arrivés ils sont rentrés dans
l'église après juste le roi alors que
c'était
un truc à faire dans toute leur vie
sans déconner
autre chose à [__] non mais sans
déconner William et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
à faire qu'est-ce qu'ils ont à faire
d'autre d'aller au couronnement de leurs
armes le gars il a un truc à faire dans
toute la vie qu'on lui demande il arrive
en retard mais c'est un énorme remorque
je dis frère je t'ai demandé une chose
on m'a dit tu as plus rien tu me donnes
le carrosse là je donne rien c'est fini
si tu me fais partir dans un carrosse
qui fait trois tonnes et demi avec 7 8
chevaux sur 5 minutes
je crois en vélo
les enfants
ils leur dis oh c'est comment ça va nous
coûter des conneries
dis-moi alors il y avait Emmanuel et
Brigitte Macron oui avec une toute
petite faute de la part peut-être de la
première dame elle était snapchat
c'était possible
on fait non tu as pas de chapeau tu sors
non non
c'est pas obligatoirement
et qu'il a pas trouvé sa place va la
chercher désespérément sa place Katy
Perry et c'est vraiment un officier de
la cour qui vient à la guider et
lorsqu'elle ressort elle a failli tomber
elle a failliams
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est incroyable elle me fait de la note
elle a pas de mecs
2300 places et il faut pas venir
et si on se rencontrer là-bas
je suis sûr que ça à Ken dans ma petite
côté
il a vérité il paraît qu'il y a un petit
côté de Twitter ce genre d'événements en
même temps
donc
elle aussi ça fait 80 ans qu'elle attend
officiellement officiellement
officiellement parce qu'il parle pas ils
étaient en tourné international et il
est très difficile
c'est compliqué parce que entre position
chanté pour Charlotte c'est
une comment dire c'est un petit peu
renié la mémoire de Diana
alors les souvenirs restent très
présents en anglais ceux qui chantent
pour ce Charles c'est un peu pour des
Américains ne pas prendre position et la
terre est médiatique honnêtement c'est
rien n'était absolument pas le même que
lors du jubilé d'Elisabeth II en juin ou
tous se sont produits devant la place du
Palais donc avoir à côté aussi pour une
internationale c'est difficile
franchement tout ça pour même pas 2
milliards de téléspectateurs oui je sais
bien que c'est énorme et le concert n'a
pas fait ça
et bien oui il se dit que en effet mais
vous savez moi je pense Cyril
il va nous impressionner énormément
quelque chose me dit qu'il va
révolutionner le système monarchie qui a
plus de 1000 ans il ne serait pas
étonnant que ce soit le premier roi ça
n'engage que moi à accepter
après un moment pour laisser sa place à
William il est conscient de la fragilité
de la monarchie il est conscient moi je
parierai que je parierai qu'il va faire
une parenthèse de quelques alarmes
c'était le premier là premier pas fait
que j'ai acheté quoi
je voulais dire que les Anglais certains
anglais grande partie des Anglais encore
un grand problème avec Camilla parce que
je rappelle que Elisabeth son mari était
presque n'était pas roi le mari
d'Elizabeth II et donc la Camilla elle
est reine NASA
ça veut dire reste toute la journée à la
maison
préfère quand même au protocole la
dernière reine 1937
Halloween regardez les regardez qui a
été William Kate et William pas
compliqué
vous êtes là
il y a une galère vous allez voir vous
allez en avoir des galettes
exactement ce que c'est qu'une galère
moi voilà donc Kate et William voilà
Queen et dans le fond on ne voit pas du
tout la robe bien sûr parce que la robe
elle est en dessous de cette femme en
direct bleu roi qui est l'ordre de
Victoria savoir que l'ordre de Victoria
Cyril c'est un des ordres les plus
prestigieux de la monarchie bride voilà
la reine la reine
je vous disais tout à l'heure vous voyez
là le bandeau floral réalisé par McQueen
mais regardez Charlotte sa fille devant
elle a la même version miniature tout
est du symbole en monarchie
[Musique]
il y avait la reine Laetitia d'Espagne
jour sur la teste
voilà vous avez encore une galère les
mecs
de la télé
pour l'instant vous pouvez juste devenir
Rennes mais la pizza
tout le monde a dit la plus marrante de
la soirée c'était la reine Anne la
princesse
on a tapé de ces barres avec un frère
avec la princesse Anne mes frères c'est
très drôle ça fait quoi parce que
regardez le chapeau le Bitcoin c'est
celui de son régiment les blouses and
royal et regardez elle a une plume une
aigrette bleue et bien elle était assise
au deuxième rang et juste derrière elle
qu'est-ce qui avait mais juste pile dans
la même trajectoire arrive ce qui veut
dire que et je suis certain que ce n'est
pas du hasard lorsque la BBC tentait de
zoomer pour avoir des photos d'Harry
vous voyez pas une fois sur deux on ne
le voyez pas parce qu'il était caché par
le plus beau
[Applaudissements]
la cérémonie de ridicule qu'est-ce que
tu dis elle est ridicule pourquoi
pourquoi tu as pas trouvé ridicule la
cérémonie la cérémonie ridicule je
conçois qu'on ne puisse pas forcément
être touché maintenant je crois qu'il
faut quand même reconnaître que il y a
quand même que les Windsor pour faire
vivre aujourd'hui un protocole sortie du
fond des âges je rappelle quand même les
grands Kings de cette cérémonie 1066 il
date de 1066 et de et du couronnement de
Guillaume le Conquérant et malgré cela
même si les chiffres sont pas terribles
vous le dites quand même ils réussissent
quand même à ramener sur ce milliards de
télé bien sûr bien sûr donc tu es
content moi je fais oui je suis content
et donc et donc tu as [__] maintenant
tu vas te faire chier
genre parce que le 17 juin c'est le
troping le premier shopping la grande
parade aux couleurs vous verrez on en
reparlera il va sortir
officiellement le 17 juin son
anniversaire
Achard dis-moi à tous les moyens alors
que vous savez quoi il est né le 14
novembre
mais je vous expliquerai pourquoi je
vous expliquerai pourquoi mais pourquoi
parce que la tradition veut que en
Angleterre on célèbre l'anniversaire des
rois au mois de juin parce que le soleil
il a plus de chance d'être de la partie
au mois de novembre
[Rires]
et bah tu me mets le 17 juillet tu
t'emmerdes pas et on pourrait peut-être
une toute dernière petite chose qui a
été appréciée par les fashionatas du
monde entier c'est que la reine je
voulais dire tu avais fait vivre tu as
fait un cahier sa robe par Bruce
allfield et bien elle a fait le elle a
fait broder les initiales de ses enfants
et elle a fait broder ses deux chiens
ces deux jack russel et on les a vu sur
la photo que vous avez diffusé tout à
l'heure les deux chiens de la reine ont
été brodés elle voulait vraiment c'est
fait broder son American stuff